no I was thinking display the side of 96
I then applied 9600 one that's a good
idea but at least I have some idea about
this opening okay playing international
master IRC it feels like I've played
them before alia scene from Egypt but it
is not the case and to a completely new
holding this is my very low rating from
I am but you never know i mean the if
you have for international masters here
from the Arabian area of Africa
sometimes they got their title-winning
some junior contest and they never
really got to a chu IM strength
sometimes this is the case let's see
what mr. you feel about you now you get
international master title for for
example winning a continental junior
championship and sometimes that doesn't
mean that they have anything here i am
strength anyway we'll see what happens
he plays where he played this very young
and very well i played my i played my
special chico ring line maybe i can
irritate him with this move you should
play 91 alright well that's not a good
move enough the 91 white is better but
you never know maybe you feel tempted to
take nope so let's see and i want some
pressure there against age three and g4
so that not so easily here he goes ok so
here
it's interesting night takes h3 does not
work but
this is closed I mean take it even
taking on g4 it's very close to working
[Music]
I am too tempted right I mean I I don't
think it works objectively speaking with
it is not easy at all friend play Queen
Airy made is the simple thing if he
takes that opens up my look and Bishop
f65 I mean that's not easy femme Queen
edge for is also on like if you move the
night clean edge for Queen h3 is pretty
bad that's not easy let's see what movie
plays I'm not sure so here I am I have
to check and then then window is night
age three I mean I don't know if you had
a good defense really it looked
difficult to do yeah now Queen f4 is
good all night f9 h3 h3 is probably
stronger right reason yeah I'm really
not sure I mean when I played it I
wouldn't totally convinced by the
captioning but it felt difficult for
wider in it let's let's have a look at
what the engine is saying probably it
doesn't work but it was the not easy to
do so the engine says it's taking on g5
but it's not a win for wine and so here
taken okay that that lost is cleared the
engine wants to take on g5 and here i
thought that means i have two pawns I
have Bishop f6 to e5 potentially look at
for all kinds of things ok this is the
engine suggestions ok
the other check the chick isn't doing
all that much it would be cool to play G
for Bishop g5 but it's going to page one
so here look at one is pretty bad that
doesn't work and so Queen D 7f indicated
by the column silhouette I have to look
at for the bishop this Bishop idea when
engine just give slight a slight edge
which is interesting I given them a
piece down for porn ever to pawn so it
wasn't totally wacky and it was
difficult I mean you're not you're right
doesn't like to take on g5 in general
but he may be have to do it I mean yeah
that's the mating idea and what are you
doing against it it's not easy we saw
looked you too I mean this year is that
a move engine doesn't find the wind for
me i was thinking i can at least take a
check here and then night h3 again yeah
it was a bit it was of course from
speculation here and fire from ok 90
seems unlikely that i've played that
again g takes us good ship takes now
look Jake Wow
this is easy for a computer and not for
a human I'm probably just threatening
look she ate stuff funny yeah so it
wasn't completely completely and
completely off that sacrifice but semi
correct probably yeah thanks for
watching